hello hello yeah hello what's your name
Catherine Catherine and we're a you
Catherine
so Hampton okay I was sort of hoping for
global but there you go so that
Southampton's good and what do you do at
Southampton Catherine I work in the
nursing team a GP surgery down here the
NHS okay so is a GP surgery kind of less
under pressurize it a bit calmer for you
guys than the hospitals the same about
the same okay well thank you very much
for for doing this it's very kind of you
okay Catherine off you go with your
story okay so a few years I was at an
X's family wedding oh yeah so we were
all outside for the group pitches and
the boys were at the back and the girls
at the front so I put my hands behind my
back and squeezed and groped my
ex-partners [ __ ] and bulls and she's a
nurse everyone she's a nurse well I
didn't realize was because my ex-partner
was best man the he had new places with
his dad so essentially what I was doing
it stood in a field on a really hot
summer's day squeezing my ex
father-in-law's penis and testicles I
like that sorry I think you can walk off
you go yeah walk walk by kind of glad
she's not in the studio
[Music]
you